or the anti Mars law is not something
new
many country in the world including some
states in America unity of America
Canada France Germany Denmark Russia
Austria already have an Tomas law we
think that the experience in Canada can
be an example for Hong Kong because
Canada law an Tomas law is as now who
Newtonian gold it's a little bit loose
and and can be can be applied to Hong
Kong but we we think that we do need
some time to further discuss about the
details of the law but we think that
that is one of the way it's not the
absolute solution but it's one of the
solution that can can help handle
today's Hong Kong critical situation we
say that there is absolutely no need for
an anti mass war in Hong Kong and we do
not see how an anti mass law will
actually resolve the current situation
in Hong Kong because the people of Hong
Kong understand that we have the crisis
of course in our hands but by having
more laws imposed on the Hong Kong
people that will restrict and seriously
kertel the basic human rights and
freedoms of the Hong Kong people will
only make the matter worse
I hope the authorities by now should
have listened to the Hong Kong people
that they yearning for freedom liberty
and democracy are not going to go away
simply because you enact even more
draconian laws to suppress the human
rights of the Hong Kong people and I
stress that this emergency regulation if
use will damage the rule of law in Hong
Kong
it will serve to further restrict the
our human rights and freedom of the Hong
Kong people